however if you guys get another one no
I'll get a third
one stop saying things don't say it so
if we if we do a everyone this side I'll
get a third hypothetically I'll get a
hypothetically this is hypothetical one
down your chest what would have to
happen for us to get the other
[Music]
one welcome back to careful boys where
we fear everybody all the time all the
time and today we are talking about what
our wives think of
us damn it's not
good I don't think it's really like that
positive do you sometimes look at her
and go why did you marry me yeah I asked
her that all the time like what the [__]
is wrong with what's her answer to that
um she's like she just stays
quiet uncomfortably quiet last night she
was asking me she was like do you think
I'm crazy I was like what does that like
what do you mean like it sounds like a
trap yeah sounds like a trap and then I
told her I was like I don't think you're
unstable like I think
you're that's a good answer more
adjectives into the conversation and
their backfire yeah a little bit but
then and then I go I asked her I was
like I was like do you think I'm crazy
do you think I'm stable you know she
goes no I think you're very normal and I
go really normal you just say what you
mean by normal boring normal yeah she
should turn it around on she goes I
think you're weird and I go you're not
wrong I think I'm weird too but like
that's what she says to me like should I
be offended when she says that to me
does how what's the tone it's like kind
of cute it's like nice it's like I think
your no dude that's kind FLIR dude yeah
she's flirting you think I missed the
ball though yeah she's down a clown dude
I think you could have [__] I think
you could have
[__] once again it goes [__] over
my head you didn't even know she was
into you I just like Fu you're an idiot
um let's go to bed that's what I tell
her next time grab her face in the
second that's really good i' be doing
that like yo chill that's when you push
harder and go for the [__] immediately
just start attacking I just watched the
video they love that [__] this is what
Steve
said are you coming yet are you coming
yet did you come though drives crazy
drives down Sick how many times you come
ask how many times you come how many
times oh
good what a question brilant
dude seeing what happens you got to test
it out yo like pushing a button um I I
think there's only nothing but boring
answers from tip I think she sometime
she'll she'll be very nice and be like
oh no I love you what are you talking
about but deep down I'll I'll never
accept that all right so can you like
draw can you draw the way that she
thinks of you in like a graph based off
of events that happen for example like
the when you like won your first fight
or lost your first fight or like when
you join JK or when you like started
your online class like you know what I
mean things that you did I don't think
she gives a [__] about any of that what
does she give a [__] about I feel like a
lot of women don't what does she give a
[__] about then I think she gives a [__]
about like the time I spend with her and
that's why she gets mad when I'm working
a lot it's like a '90s movie you know in
your head you think like oh I'm being
productive I'm [__] getting after
babe like what do you think and then
she's like where the [__] have you been
and you're like whoa not like that but
but it's more like working for us yeah
I'm like May I'm working she's like but
what's the point of you working if
what's the point of us being married if
we can't hang out and do stuff and I go
[__] that's true that's a blanket
statement yeah but like she needs
quality time Nick that's what I'm saying
and that's her that's her number one
love language I guess next to getting
fingered would you rather have quality
time or a [__] roof over our heads I
was like if I don't I don't get time off
bro if I don't work I'm [__] I'm
assed out you know what I mean but um I
get it there's a balance and I feel like
sometimes she she gives me [__] about if
you push it to the extreme you think she
she'll be down to she be she's the bread
winner and you just stay at home and
then she could access to you 24/7 I kind
of think she would like that really yeah
cuz there was a time where I was like
the past couple weeks I I've been just
working from home and not really seeing
that many clients and I just been
hanging with dog and she kind of [__]
likes it but then when I'm gone all day
and I come home later like hey babe
let's hang out she's like I'm tired you
know yeah it's like so she wants you to
be the housewife I like bro I could be I
could be domestic as [__] yo she's going
to finger blast you yeah and but I'd be
way more receptive I just [__] you so
she's not receptive to your finger
blasting maybe what does she think about
your nature of enjoying
life what does that
mean like like like how I I blend like
how I blend work with with play like
that yeah everything got CL I'm really
trying to take it
seriously but I just threw something out
I know I know you he shooting a shot
dude yeah but yeah going back to what
tip said about like career stuff I think
she really doesn't give a [__] I think
she really likes me for me which is
makes me question what's you then what's
you then yeah what would she say about
you to her girlfriend to her girlfriend
yeah to her what what do you think she
thinks about you what do she what do you
think she says about you to her mom oh
yeah like this is why I'm with this dude
she [__] married you for some reason
this is like one of the hardest
questions I think maybe you should call
right now I think cuz I'm I'm fun you
are a fun guy but not when you're always
gone cuz you treat us the same way yeah
everybody here knows that you're the
funniest guy cuz you're consistently
here but are you consistently there
she's working a damn it I was going to
say call her and ask her what do you
really think of me what do you really
think when you say she's working is she
working at the office or at the home at
the home but like she she has to do like
you'll catch that's not real [__]
she's washing dishes or some [__]
no she's actually working she she's like
doing sessions and stuff you know oh oh
she has actual sessions get that show
ISM away from me yeah yeah she's not
just typing away even that is a part of
her job but um I I think she thinks I'm
a fun time I think she you're a fun guy
I'm a fun
guy good [__]
man this is good [__] we might not dig
out of this one I think she thinks I'm
fun yeah she thinks I cook well is this
good
content she says I make good food you
know like that's that's good sounds like
Tiff has low
standards
honestly 100% no like full disclosure I
think she does shut up I think she has
awful standards are you serious for
everything really cute or for for her
choice in men both so you think you
think okay let's let's extrapolate this
you think if you guys broke up the next
be with some bum
loser but still better than
me here's what just happened we threw
out a joke WFT and Nick swam to it and
now he's he's hanging on to that she'd
be with a homeless black belt no I think
about that a lot I I no these These are
conversations I have with her like we
actually do talk about this I'm like you
think that [__] is cute I'm like
this [__] not cute at all I
think all [__] are cute
I have low standards don't you
remember what about you Anthony yeah go
to Anthony let's go to some with higher
level let's go to a higher level got
[__] dude does n know go why you out
there dancing all day when are you going
to stop dancing and and do some man [__]
I mean but she's a dancer too so she
kind of gets it yeah I think uh I think
she's very practical like me it's like
she'll be sad if I'm like doing a thing
and I'm gone but then the second I tell
her like how much I'm making she's be
like go go go
go what's the number dude it's okay you
know it's the Asian in her she she do
she has medium standards medium
standards definitely not high but
definitely not low um do you do you
think that that she thinks you're smart
you want to know what's really funny
that like like kind of almost hurts me
sometimes but it doesn't cuz it's like a
joke that's just been like a 10e bit
that we have literally the first 3 years
that we were together she thought I was
perfect oh yeah I could do no wrong she
was infatuated like I she literally the
word is perfect 3 years is a long time
of maintaining that title too and you
know in those three years probably my
heaviest traveling years so I was like
just gone the most so it's like I can I
couldn't really show the flaws she
didn't hear you diarrhea in the bathroom
yet that's tips
SC cuz the minute you start hearing
those real sounds once you're putting
the thumb over the [__] hose yeah
yeah you're no longer like a
mysterious trophy especially when it's
mostly
water diarrhea is the leading cause of
divorce these days but that's why I feel
like in My Graph first three years I
feel like my stock was just Rising what
anything whether it was like the things
I was doing in life my my personality I
was fun time whatever it's like dude
purely positive XY just all the way up
right and then there was a moment of
plateau and I don't know if it's ever
grown from there and I think just length
of time made it worth it to just stick
around that's beautiful
Anthony damn that's [__]
beautiful what about every Jackson Wayne
concert it's got to go she must be like
oh that's the man I'm mared yeah when
you're carrying Jackson Wang on your
freaking shoulder look at all Jack
covered in paint right that's cool does
Nina know like it I do like it that's no
cuz you're wear mask no it's cuz they're
all Asians up there that's why it's all
a bunch of Asians with Go's up there
yeah
about this about during this Plateau
right during this Plateau we all got the
the tattoo together oh dude did it go
here or did it go there oh oh yeah can I
say that dropped for me no no I don't
want why did it drop for you yeah dude
she looked at me like what are you a
[__] idiot that's what she thought
really Nikki I'll be in the kitchen
she's just like cuz I'm wearing shorts
yeah she's
like that's her love
language I wish there's no part of that
and people will be like what do you
think of Nick's tattoo she's like I
[__] hate it that's what she says
Nikki giggles and then I'm like what are
you giggling at she's like you're stupid
[__]
tattoo Hannah's mom congratulated us and
she said it looks cool and I was like do
you know what it means and she goes no
and I'm like you know what the backstory
she goes no I just know you guys had a
pack and you all committed that's cool
she that is pretty cool though I got to
tell her the real story and she's going
to be like that's stupid never tell her
tell her at her [__] obituary dude
never [__] tell tell her tell her at
her obituary yes that makes sense right
yeah so for Nina did it go down or did
it go uh I think she was extremely
conflicted but I do think that it's the
the top tattoo that she thinks is the
dumbest number one number one seed [__]
yeah dude but sometimes the dumbest is
the
best do you think those Power Rankings
will change or do you think like am I
going to go get a dumber tattoo yeah
maybe if I got a second one on my other
[__] dude the second one's pretty crazy
the [__] would do that all right today
we were training with Bart and I was
like holy [__] dude you have two of
those
tattoos and I'm like oh my God this is
crazy and I look at the mirror and I see
one on my [__] [__] all right we're
not we're not supposed to talk about
tattoos anymore because every time we
talk about them we get one yeah let's
not but but but however if you guys get
another one no I'll get a third
one stop saying things don't say it so
if we if we do a fe everyone on this
side
I'll get a third hypothetic I'll get
hypothetically this is hypothetical one
down your chest what would have to
happen for us to get the other one no
[__] way dude I don't want to high in
the sky delete this I'm talking about
dreams delete this want two I'm talking
about dream your
work I have I already have a tattoo on
this I don't want it to go over it could
be covered up I'd rather get cauliflower
ear first all right dude that's rude
that's rude that hurt my feelings
where's the third one go that's way more
pain the
back dude if you do one down your chest
bro that'd be crazy no it has to keep
with the theme no no no no it's like by
the end of our lifetime we're going to
have a tube sock of the same [__]
tattoo leg are just
C blasted legs of the same bad tattoo
that's so stupid Oh no dude yeah we have
Dum ideas more tattoo talk too many dumb
ideas it's a pretty interesting idea
though yeah have you guys like looked at
the tattoo like there times throughout
your day where you look at the tattoo
and you go oh [__] I have a tattoo on my
sh I bet for me and Steve every time I
see myself yet dude I just was I just
saw my mom and I was like accidentally
wearing shorts cuz I had to move
furniture and [__] like that right and
then she looks at and she's like you got
another one she doesn't like him when I
get him right and then she's like you
know I don't like that right and then I
I she's like why'd you get it and I
stood there're so conflicted yeah dude
what are you saying tell her the real
story tell tell the reason
what do you tell people bro cuz in my
head I was like okay what what would
Steve do I was like this mean this means
the coolest thing in the world of course
it meant a lot to me right but I just
didn't know how to lie that well in that
moment so I just went like
this not that's a good one not terrible
and she was like she's like you know I
don't like that and she walked away and
I was like Wow cuz when people ask me
like why'd you get the tattoo I'm like
do you have 10 minutes to spare for me
to tell you the whole story like that's
the worst part
such a good story usually after the eth
minute they're like oh that's cool and
then they and then they walk away I was
walking around my neighborhood I was
taking a different route than usual and
there was kind of like a crazy Sun
bleach like desert guy walking around
and I was wearing shorts and he's like
hey hey what's the tattoo mean and I was
like ah you know it's don't worry about
it he's like no no what's it mean what's
it mean he's like I was like a it's like
my my Grandpa's in the military he and
the guy like he's like oh I served in
the military what what what what is it
he's like he's like I have a tattoo and
he's like showing me his tattoo same one
and then I was like oh it means like um
you my grandpa was in the Marines and
and then he's like okay and I'm like and
and he's like so so what like your
grandpa's Asian and I'm like yeah it's
like the three ninjas say that it's even
harder to not explain it three
ninas he has one eye like this and he
just I have two white parents and a
Asian grandparents just like three
ninjas my name's Rocky by the
way okay back to what our W yeah what
what what about you Bart it does mean
dumbest well my wife thinks I'm part of
the dumbest men on Earth crew
yes the dumbest man on Earth this is
what she literally texted me when we're
getting the tattoo throw that text up in
the screen right now two M's I love this
shirt that's how [__] dumb we are
we're on top of the world baby we are
the world it's all six of us too that's
pretty sweet oh my God I like how we're
all the same
height you can go get this shirt the
link is in the description you can go
get this shirt right now it is live it's
real get it so you could be a part of
the dumbest men on Earth crew that needs
to be on the wall by the way some of
these logos need to be on the wall huh
need be no no no no we don't want to
take down oil
Mexico dude it's like really hammered in
here by the way that shirt's available
now too you're going to wreck our
aesthetic in here man what are we doing
what are we doing took a lot of work
took a lot of work to you know how long
it took to take [__] Bar's dumbass
painting
down hey is that up there hey that's
[__] up
dude I do think there are times when our
wives just look at us like what the [__]
and then there's other times when I
think they just look at us like we're
children yeah mhm they might both be the
same mhm that's kind of the same yeah
it's interchangeable right Nikki
definitely um you know yeah the tattoo
thing was pretty is has been pretty fun
because she really thinks that we're
[__] dumb right um would you say the
dumbest man Earth yeah I would my
favorite thing about about what I try to
do every year is I try to just get a
little bit better at something so it'll
blow Nikki's mind right so like like
cooking recently I've been I've been
cooking bre breakfast and [__] like that
yeah and she like thinks like I'm a
[__] like I'm like Chef Gordon ramsy
and [__] dude that's a good one if you
learn how to cook you can impress your
lady dude I made I make tacos every week
vegan tacos oh yeah vegan tacos what the
hell is it made of it's soyo all that
seed oil
[__] it's so bad yeah right it's even
worse only once a week so I can't can
that kill you I don't know probably not
I do vegan tacos I do um I do stuffed p
peers now with and I do like turkey meat
for me and I do her vegan meat for her
that's kind of sick right and this is
all basic [__] it's like four
ingredients it's like not a big deal but
you're cooking though but I'm cooking
now and like 5 years ago I didn't even
know how to cook anything I couldn't
cook an egg oh yeah isn't it isn't it
satisfying when you cook like a nice
meal I like doing I like you know what
it is I like taking care of her it's my
favorite thing like I like knowing that
like if she's hungry like when she says
she's hungry like it [__] kills me
like you don't tell her shut up cuz you
never know how to choose what to eat
I wish no I do that too I feel that way
yeah I like I like knowing that okay
she's taking care of now I can now I can
do my [__] what a life skill are you
going to have to learn when you get the
other Shin
tattooed why would I because you guys
are cowards you guys will never [__]
agree to do it n don't do that don't do
that we make it happen here you'll never
agree to do it what's your price just
name your price it could be ridiculous
you could be like oh when JK news hits
100 million Subs that'll literally never
happen so easy what's your price what's
price 3 million subscribers I don't want
to I don't want a low ball like we did
before want to a for the sky the other
one was ex low that was the biggest
lowball surviving one year is not a big
deal we found out we it was going to be
you got honestly you got to think about
the ratio even to hit 3 million that's a
way bigger jump than what we did to hit
2 million but no one even said 2 million
the fans pushed us to it correct
although it happened at the same time I
have to say it was funny watching that
video back and Joe being like we don't
even know where this came from and it
cussed Joe literally saying it he's
literally the one who started the idea
came from his mouth he's like we don't
even know what happened where'd it come
from that's most Joe [__] do it and then
he he like started the Manhunt to find
out who said
it he's like we need to find this guy
man made let's do it we're [__] Joe
what's what's hand think are you I think
sometimes she looks at at me like I'm
her [__] like number one savior man
in the world and another times I think
she looks at me like I'm a helpless dumb
[__] that just came out of the Jungle
she needs to fix that's marriage baby
and then I'm like which one is it are
you my damel are you my damel in
distress that needs saving or am I the
[__] dumb [__] that you're cradling
yeah I don't know it's both you need
both I think I feel like there's yeah
sometimes yeah sometimes you just need
to be a dumb [__] yeah but the thing is
I think she thinks it's what I do is
dumb a lot of the times like the tattoo
and stuff but she's encouraging a it and
I think she eggs it on because it's so
funny to her yeah so instead of it
saying no it's like she's like yeah do
it and then she has a great sense of
humor she laughs at me yeah and then
before I know I was like oh you're were
just laughing does smack just think
you're utterly perfect in every way
she's so she's so supportive redheads
are just supportive creatures they have
no souls but they're very suppor even
like the the tattoo like when I showed
it to her or I was talking to her about
it before we got it she's like oh that's
so cool get a tattoo with your friends
it's so cool and and then I like showed
it to her and she's like oh looks so
cool she's so like like so purp there's
not a single thing that you do that
she's like that's [__] dumb I'm sure
there's a lot of them but she's so good
at not making me pay for it like she's
just so supportive dude yeah what about
when you buy like some shitty ass van
she she loves it she likes it she does
the same thing she buys like all kinds
of she she has a drives a Nova as a
daily bro do you think it's like a
that's cool as [__] though what about
when you're like going down and you have
like nothing but hair yeah [__] she
doesn't say move trim that [__]
bird's nest dude I she's so like
non-critical of me it's like it's scary
yeah I'm wondering if it's like a
British girl thing that they don't
[__] call you out on your [__]
like Latinos do I think it's just a
non-american thing I think it's a Latin
thing they're like too polite right so
you're saying they don't complain no
they do but like different like oh how
how do they complain I think it's like
so polite that it goes over our heads
their complaining is so polite it goes
overhead that's not complaining then but
it is to them it's like their version
cuz I think aies and British are more
closer than Americans and British well
also she's from she's from log in
Australia it's like a very like Bogan
town it's like kind of a like she's so
laidback you know what I mean she's like
a redneck basically well same with
Hannah she's like you know she's a
northern Sydney let me ask you this is
she a bed
maker no we're both not we just leave it
what's the thing in your life that are
you guys aren't the same
I skin color oh yeah yeah there's got to
be something you guys aren't the same
it's probably annoying the amount of
time that I put to like like if I'm
playing a video game forever that's
probably really she's probably just like
uh yeah I lost him for 6 hours and then
what would she what does she say to sh
her life nothing you know what she does
she she makes me food and puts it in
front of me get the [__] out of here
dude what the [__] turn off the [__]
video now end the video you don't
deserve this shirt yeah dude [__] you
[__] I knew it I knew it but it's
because we're not
married just kidding news careful boys
is a brand just kidding news is the man
of smart people the people of just
kidding news careful boys they are very
smart just kidding news the number one
podcast in the
world